what is what what is this you [ __ ]
call this grass that's the worst grass
I've seen in my life
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you doing
are you would it stop twitching you've
got damn cow all right so we have some
demon cows in a grass simulator game
great just what I had hope
stop oh god this is terrifying all right
you know what I'm going in no more grass
for me oh god the grass is everywhere oh
it's everywhere
make the Kratt again really like hey go
shoot the grass or take this grass
you'll never get me ah infinite demo
slow-mo shooting that grass 360 360
noscope
alright the grass is still alive I don't
know what to do do I shoot the cows I'm
sorry demon cow you fatty
Oh can't kill them can kill the devil
huh
Oh